[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream extra special
Tuesday edition is it Tuesday extra
special Tuesday edition this is the
171 second
172nd live stream that we have done yet
in all that time I have remained Dr
Brett Weinstein you Dr Heather Hein
and we are uh we are here having just
returned yesterday from a fantastic
Excursion ready to confront
some of what has happened in the
meantime and uh yeah other issues are
rising which we may say a little bit
here at the top of the hour but uh
you're not going to call me out on
second
you didn't call me out on 71th or
whatever I said that's true yeah so I
you know how dare you not correct me sir
it's like a a microcosm of mutual
assured destruction we've both aired and
neither of us are going to point it out
and presumably no one in the audience is
paying close enough attention to notice
I think that's probably right yeah all
right
um so here we are we are not gonna do a
q a today we will be back on Saturday
this Saturday and we will do our usual
live stream and our usual q a at our
usual time 12 30. our dog is walking
around wondering why we haven't provided
her place to to sleep I apologize she's
gonna have to stay away for the whole
thing and usually we put her to sleep so
you can't say that about dogs usually
you provide a sort of a soporific
effects the means for sleeping because
the dogs
yes maybe she'll jump up on the table
and sleep right there all right um
today being Tuesday which is the day
that I always post to Natural Selections
um I've got a new post today and I want
to say a few things about that too after
we do on the top of the hour stuff but
as always you can find me at natural
selections.substack.com
uh we have our book hunter-gatherers
Guide to the 21st century and we are of
course supported by you our audience we
encourage you to subscribe like share
videos that you are seeing on YouTube or
Odyssey or if you're listening on
um any any of the normal places that you
might be listening rather than also
watching a podcast and you can also
consider joining one of our patreons we
have
um monthly conversations you have
monthly conversations with a select view
at yours and we do private q and A's at
mine and on both of them you can also
get access to the Discord server where
there's lots of great conversations
going on all the time
and of course we have sponsors as usual
we start off top of the hour three ads
from sponsors whom we really do actually
vouch for uh here we go
all right our first sponsor this week is
brand new to us cured c-u-r-e-d cured
makes no Tropics in a market
increasingly full of such products but
cured sent us several of their lines and
I have tried and benefited from many of
them today I want to specifically talk
about their product called rise designed
to be taken in the morning or whenever
mental Clarity energy and focus is your
desired State rise was formulated by
keurig's own in-house clinical herbalist
I've tried it several times and each
time find a subtle but definitely
noticeable difference in my tendency to
stay on task and get things done quickly
and efficiently I truly appreciate this
product Rise by cured ingredients and
Rise include lion's mane for mental
Clarity and energy cordyceps to enhance
oxygen utilization not to make you turn
into a zombie in the Amazon which other
cordyceps find us do but this is a
different courtesy it's a big claim yeah
wide range of effects that was just for
those of you who have more familiarity
with um Amazonian fungus than you do
with no Tropics which is I think two of
us yes perhaps and we're here but I
gotcha thank you thank you so
ingredients rise include lion's mane and
cordyceps and CBD and ginseng and
huperzia Serrata which I found that
interesting I thought I don't know what
that is so I looked it up and check it
out who parent who perzia Serato which
is the Latin binomial scientific name
for a Club Moss that has been used in
Chinese herbal medicine for a long time
a long time to alleviate memory loss and
reduce inflammation and derivatives of
this very same species have been begun
to be used in Western medicine to treat
Alzheimer's disease so this is a memory
enhancing
Club moss plant
that has been used in both Chinese and
Western medicine or the actual Club Moss
is used in Chinese medicine and as is
its want Western medicine has form has
pulled out one molecule and is using
that
cured's rise blend of functional
mushrooms adaptogens and Canadian fluids
will leave your brain on fire but in a
good way that was their line I decided
to keep it in there
um
rain on fire yeah well all right yep
makes sense and it'll help you get your
to-do list tackled the values that cured
holds highest incinerate your to-do list
yeah with your brain on fire I don't
know I mean yes incinerate your to-do
list could mean out of hell with this
it's good either way it's nailed
everything on it or I think you could
use some Rise
by Keurig their values as stated on
their website are nature responsibility
and service and they say quote we are
more than just our products we are
stewards of the plants we represent
Health as a combination of movement
mindfulness and daily action I like that
very much carrot also does third party
testing of all their hemp derived CBD
products and makes those test results
available on its site such testing is
not a legal requirement but allows
customers to be certain that cured
products are free of harmful
contaminants like pesticides and heavy
metals rise is only one of many of
kieran's products they also make Zen a
product designed for afternoons and
evenings a sleep bundle that
incorporates CBD with a Zen product and
so many more they are so likely to have
the no Tropic that is right for you
right now cured is extending an
exclusive offer to you our listeners you
can get rise or any of kirid's other
fantastic products for 20 off by
visiting
www.curednutrition.com Dark Horse and
use code coupon code Darkhorse at
checkout that's c-u-r-e-d nutrition
c-u-r-e-d-n-u-t-r-i-t-i-o-n.com slash
Darkhorse and use coupon code Darkhorse
at checkout to save 20 percent seriously
try it it's good stuff really is
our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost helping bring audio
Clarity and capacity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it we
don't have need for hearing aids but we
have a friend who does so we asked her
to assess this product carefully and
honestly she did in her testimony her
testimonial will follow
MD hearing aid was founded by any
let's start the paragraph again MD
hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford he keeps the price
Low by simplifying the product removing
several rarely needed components and he
made a product that aims to fit so well
no one will know you're wearing it other
features include rechargeable batteries
that last up to 30 hours water
resistance and up to three feet of water
in their vault plus model and you don't
need a prescription to get one MD
hearing aid is cut out the middle man so
you buy your hearing aid directly from
the source where audiologists and
licensed hearing Specialists are
available seven days a week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from that friend of
ours who a substantial hearing loss on
who relies on hearing aids we asked her
to try this here this product and this
is what she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech I wear the MD hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voiced man in a room with a lot of white
noise the empty hearing aid passed the
test as my conversation partner's voice
was clear and understandable at a price
point of under a thousand dollars I was
amazed at how effective they are
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
empty hearing aid recently cut their
price in half so if you want empty
hearing aids smallest hearing aid yet go
to mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Dark Horse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids cost
just
149.99 plus Darkhorse listeners receive
a free extra charging case an additional
hundred dollar value again head to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids for only
149.99
the the charging case do we know if it
is it is a hard case
I'm going to assume so then we should
call it a hard charging case I think
that would be cool yes note to sponsor
or charging case hard charging case
right be the first one in your block
all right our final sponsor this week is
Vivo Barefoot who makes shoes four feet
everyone should try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
feet vivos however are made by people
who actually know feet and word is
spreading people often approach us
because of the vivos we're wearing
saying they've heard they're good and
they are these shoes are every bit as
good as you have heard you will love
them here at Dark Horse we love them
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you are
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo
barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up but strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they are a certified B
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on the Solid Surfaces of it
go to vivobarefoot.com and use the code
Darkhorse 15 to get an exclusive 15 off
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the code
darkhorse15 at checkout
so they're not Jesus shoes
we're trying to imply here's the thing
I have tried them and I fall right
through the surface of the water but
that could be me
you know what I'm saying me and almost
everyone else yeah I think it is you but
it's not just you not it's not just me
right no that's that's that's right yeah
all right uh well you have I think a
number of things you want to talk about
today
um I wanted to start there's some stuff
that if we get to it at the end I'd love
to but I'd love to start by uh just
talking a little bit about the season
before you embark on on some of your
plans here it is uh those of you who are
in the northern hemisphere will have
noticed spring and the farther towards
the pole you are uh the greater the
change in photo period you've been
experiencing and
um
and probably in the sort of middle range
as as we are the more likely you are
just to be in the the full flush of
spring at this point so we were just
away from the Salish Sea from the San
Juan Islands where we now live for nine
days and
um and about three weeks before that two
weeks before that we were away for
another nine days in each case we
thought ah we are going to miss so much
change here and indeed we did
and it is it is just a remarkable
reminder of the complexity and vibrancy
of the planet we live on uh to both be
in a place and watch the changes every
single day and also to go away for a
short period of time and return to a
place that you know relatively well and
see
um see how much change has occurred I
mean it's a little bit like parents
watching their children grow versus
grandparents who only see those those
grandchildren episodically oh my how
you've grown whereas if you've if you've
been there every day you may not notice
that the buds are bursting the grass is
shooting up
um all of that yeah it's amazing how
much change there was in a little over a
week yeah you know the place just looks
different feels different and the phase
of what is going on ecologically is
clearly moved on substantially that's
right
so there are a number of natural history
stories that probably we want to tell in
more depth when you've got some of your
um or Toby's even our 17 year olds
photographs queued up to include some of
them
um but I would just like to mention the
um the harbor seals that we get to spend
time with uh nearly every day here who
show up and look with interest at our
dog at our Labrador when she shows up on
the shore uh with us it makes me wonder
what they think about what is going on
on land I I wrote at the beginning of
this year that you know I didn't exactly
make resolutions this year but I I wrote
in Natural Selections of my sub stack
that I want to befriend seals this year
and I would like to and we have been
paddle boarding a couple of times out in
amongst them I don't need to make
friends with sea lions they're a bit
um
a bit more interested in demonstrating
that they have power and they also have
much bigger teeth you want the taunt
with sea lions yes very much want to
taunt with the sea lions but uh friends
with the seals and I think they might be
interested but they're really interested
in the dog it is as if they see a
kindred spirit meaning actually in this
case kin from from not too long ago so I
would just uh for anybody who is
wondering whether you are imagining
things
the the telling signature of their
interest is that they're facing us
almost any time you're out there they're
looking at us and Maddie in particular
is a focus and they turn their heads and
watch her walk up and down yeah so they
really do seem interested I you know
there's of course a part of me that you
know worries if we took Maddie out uh on
a boat if uh you know if we went in if
we'd be safe but I do think it does it
does look more like curiosity than
anything yeah it really does
and we've also got
um
bald eagles
who are appearing to hunt Gull eggs
as far as we can tell
um Gull or goose
yeah it's it's it's it's hard to know
exactly what all is going on out there
but I don't know that we've seen Goose
um
Goose nesting in the place that the that
the Eagles go and flush the gulls off of
so this is just watching
um
watching life come back into its own as
nearly every organism at this point is
is about to start reproducing or is in
the middle of it or is already
protecting their young it is a spring is
inherently a time of of great activity
and ferocity
and we saw this up in Southeastern
Alaska where we were last week as well
you know about which again we will say
more in the future but
specifically we saw a number of sea
lions with
sea otters with with babies
which is just about one of the most
adorable things you can imagine and we
saw sea stars so I wrote about this from
my sub stack today and I will link that
in the show notes but the sea stars uh
used to be incredibly common along the
west coast of North America I remember
them from tide pools when I was growing
up in Southern California
and we have been living in the Pacific
Northwest now since 2002 and they used
to be all over the place and crested on
pilings in any kind of tide pool
situation and anytime you were in the
water such as kayaking in a shallow
Rocky Shore a shallow Rock You Know
title habitat you would find them and
high diversity too incredibly High
diversity 10 recognizable morphs I don't
know how many species but more than that
even apparently they are so the the bit
of research I did for my sub stack today
there are 1900 species worldwide
and this is not the hot spot for them
they're they're actually more diverse
and I think it was um
Indian Ocean especially in maybe
Atlantic as well but there have been
many many many species here and uh about
2013 uh there was a massive die off and
there have been some die-offs before you
know of course numbers fluctuate but uh
specifically the uh the the dominant
like the keystone predator the the first
species that was ever called the
keystone predator in the ecological
literature effect by Robert Payne
different Robert Payne than we went to
the other and the other Robert Payne so
there was a Robert Payne who was on the
faculty and ornithologist University of
Michigan this is the other Robert Payne
he literally wrote
um and I don't have it up but it's the
ocher sea star
um as such a such an effective
generalist Predator
um that it was it was this species
um that keystone predator was a term
that was uh described for first so uh
forgive me you know I don't see color
and don't pay as much attention I don't
know what ocher is but like gold gold
gold Brown yellow gold Brown so it's not
the purplish no one yeah and so this is
um
you know the the sort of conceit
um of my piece which is is short and I I
encourage those of you to read it
um
it begins this way I'll just read the
first paragraph once upon a time you
would kayak the Waters of the Sailor sea
around Seattle or Vancouver off of
Whidbey Island or orcas or Vashon and
find sea stars in a rainbow of colors
there were bright orange sea stars and
others in salmon pink some are pale
yellow many of them are rocky beige some
sport in almost luminescent blue they're
even purple ones most had five arms some
had six and some had many more than that
there were sea stars visible in any
clear water that was shallow enough to
see the sea floor
now they're almost none
and I go on and explain a bit about what
sea stars are phylogenetically and um to
what the die-off that began in 2013 has
been attributed and say
I don't buy it right that would none of
the the supposed mechanisms that have
been proposed for what is called sea
star waste and disease seem fully
explanatory and to its credit
um the research that I've read on this
acknowledges that people are kind of
making stabs and hopefully not entirely
the dark
at what is going on there but the
experience that we had in Southeastern
Alaska this week wait before you move on
to to that I just want to point out that
as this was happening as wasting disease
was beginning to be recognized this was
something you could also observe the sea
stars as they disappeared it wasn't just
simply that their numbers dropped you
could actually go to the seashore and
see animals that you know were missing a
limb and oozing and uh it was it was
quite sad and alarming if you were
familiar with these things and you know
sometimes you would find one that wasn't
wasting and it was kind of exciting and
you know at this point there you know
how many have we seen since moving up to
the San Juans in September well more
than we had seen in years but I think
we've saw three yeah yeah it was one
maybe two in the previous several years
yeah and it would literally have been
every time you looked over a dock you
would see multiples you wouldn't even
realize most of the time you know was
like background it was like looking at
trees yeah yeah no and the way that this
thing this syndrome affects these
animals looks very excruciating and
apparently
um I've learned from the bit of research
I read
uh this week the first signs that they
lose interest in food
so they stop eating first and then their
arms twist and contort and we saw that
too right they do when but the the most
sort of grotesque part of it is the
point at which they seem they're
they're tissue seems to lose coherence
right and they they sort of ooze and and
melt and
um and die and then they disappear
entirely and they're basically gone uh
except we were in we were in a double
kayak at a bay off of chichikov Island
uh west of Juno south of icy strait
south of Glacier Bay National Park this
last week in shallow water
shallow clear water at low tide
and
we saw all sorts of stuff
we saw sea cucumbers and anemones and a
little run of salmon and
um and a lot of clams opened up clam
shells and again a few otters on the
surface of the water and so many sea
stars so many sea stars and I don't know
I was not able to ascertain with regard
to that spot if somehow they never died
off there
or if they did when they're coming back
because I have heard anecdotally from
some number of people who say yep I'm on
the Sailor sea which is basically just
the the area that includes the Puget
Sound and up into the San Juan and Gulf
Islands in Seattle and Vancouver is the
biggest cities in the area
um I've heard from people in the Salish
Sea and the Sunshine Coast in British
Columbia and farther south like Oregon
coast who say yeah they they were
totally gone but I'm beginning to see
them back now so it's possible that the
colder water of Southeast Alaska which
is understood to slow the procession of
the disease but doesn't actually halt it
in its tracks maybe was a little bit
productive maybe it didn't get so far
maybe it's allowing them to come back
faster I don't know I don't know if they
were gone they're coming back or they're
always there but seeing the sea stars
there
gave me hope in a world that seems
incredibly Bleak across so many domains
including and especially ecologically it
really gave me help and uh you know we
were seeing that same you know the
conceit that I mentioned earlier of of
the pieces that I finished with
um
clamshells littered the shallow sea
floor this is again on chichikov island
in Southeast Alaska open and broken and
Scattered but the other organisms that
are not just present but abundant were
sea stars there are bright orange ones
and others in salmon pink some were pale
yellow many of them are rocky beige some
supported an almost luminescent blue
there were even purple ones most had
five arms some had sex and some had many
more than that
it looks like
um not a perfect match but a similar
match for the species that should have
been there before where we've never been
before but that we had seen in the
Sailor sea some hundreds of miles south
yeah absolutely and yeah I wish we knew
whether or not that was a change or
whether those were isolates that were
preserved through the the wasting
disease but yes it sure would be uh
wonderful if they returned that would be
a sign that whatever catastrophe had
befallen them was passing at least it
absolutely won yeah
all right excellent that's
I've said my piece you've said your
piece all right yeah for now so I guess
we're moving on to um so many many one
of the things about this trip that we
were on was that it cut us off almost
entirely from the technological World
which was alarming at first because of
we just didn't know it was coming it
would have been wonderful to to know
that in advance and we just didn't know
it was going to happen yeah so there's
lots of things one might you know put on
pause somehow and there was a scramble
and then connectivity disappeared but
being forced away from connectivity was
marvelous in its own ways I mean it's
something we used to do to our students
intentionally but we give them warning
yeah we sure did but in this case uh
something happened while we were away
that I might have missed actually I
might have missed the thing entirely if
somebody had not posted a link to it and
tagged me uh in a discussion that I'm
I'm in and
uh what it was was a New York Times
article reporting on a new scientific
result that was published in the New
England Journal of Medicine Zach if you
could put up the New York Times uh
the beginning of that article
okay the title says link between long
telomeres and long life is a tall tale
study finds now when I saw that title I
thought oh brother another supposed
debunk of the hypothesis that I advanced
in the very late 90s uh on the
relationship between
telomeres which are repetitive genetic
sequences at the ends of eukaryotic
chromosomes we are eukaryotes eukaryotic
chromosomes are linear they're not
circles
and telomeres are repetitive sequences
they're not genes they are just
sequences of DNA that repeat at the ends
of chromosomes I'll get more into what
they're about shortly but in any case
when I saw this I thought okay this is
going to be another one of these
articles where they claim without
pointing to my hypothesis directly but
they
debunk the idea that telomeres mediate a
balance between tumor suppression and
tissue repair the balance between them
creating increased longevity
that's what I thought when I saw this
title and then I started reading the
article on holy moly that is not what
this article says the uh New England
Journal of Medicine article or the New
York Times article the New York Times
article I will get to the uh the New
England Journal of Medicine article that
they are that Gina colada the reporter
who did the New York Times piece is
reporting on in a second
but
um
contrary to the implication of that
title and I will say I think uh Gina
colada has a lot to answer for in this
article it's very poorly done frankly
but she's probably not responsible for
the title the title is probably well and
you've got a headline and a sub headline
the subheadline looks um looks to tell a
slightly different story this sub
headline does tell a slightly different
tale it says the longer a person's
telomeres researchers found the greater
the risk of cancer and other disorders
challenging a popular hypothesis about
the chromosomal Roots of Vitality now I
find that subheading also very
misleading because the point is the
telomeres are at the root of Vitality
but it is not more telomere better it's
a balance much as I argued back in the
late 90s and then with my co-author
Debbie cesic published a paper
ultimately explaining the hypothesis and
the evidence surrounding it
so if you will scroll down to that first
paragraph Zach
so this again is Gina colada one of the
New York Times uh science
journalists he says the story as often
happens in science sounded so appealing
cells have a molecular clock that
determines how long they live if you can
just stop the clock cells can live
indefinitely and the same should be
should go for people who are after all
made of cells stop the cell clock and
you can remain youthful
well
well I mean but that paragraph is
directly responsive not to your
hypothesis not to what you have
published in the Journal of experimental
gerontology back in 2002 but to the sort
of Pop medicine version of that on which
basis presumably tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars of Grants have been
given right like that that is what she
is reporting on there is truly something
that people have been people who ought
to know better have have been claiming
all along people who forgot or never
knew that actually trade-offs in
everything all the time right and it's
one of the things that I was responding
to more than 20 years ago was the fact
that people were telling a biological
story that made no sense and the reason
that that story made no sense literally
never made any sense is that if it were
true that the more telomere you had the
longer you live then selection would
have a very easy time lengthening
telomeres and so there was something
implied The Limited length of telomeres
in fact that limit evolved sec
our eukaryotic uh ancestors
that were single-celled or Colonial like
yeast have telomeres that maintain their
length so that something in becoming a
complex organism resulted in the
evolution of limited length of telomeres
telomeres that shrink with time
or with cell divisions and so it was
always implied by the fact that there
was some reason to have the telomere
short right the question is what was
that reason so let me read her second
paragraph she says the clocks come in
the form of caps on the ends of
chromosome the long Twisted strings of
DNA carrying the cell's genes the caps
on chromosomes called telomeres are
chains of short repeated segments of DNA
every time a cell divides its telomere
gets a little shorter until finally they
get so short that the cell dies
well that's not true okay that's just
simply an incorrect description of what
happens it is true that cells somatic
cells that are not in a small number of
special classes do shorten with every
cell division
but it is not true that when the
telomeres get to a critical level of
shortness that the cell dies what
happens actually is that the cells go
into a different phase and the paper
that Debbie cesic and I published argued
that the the interpretation that the
field had thrown onto this second phase
was incorrect we argued that it was in
fact an Adaptive response to having
reached the end of their capacity to
reproduce and the upshot of of the paper
was that the reason to have that limit
was that it regulated The Runaway cells
where the repair capacity had been
triggered to go into a phase that was
unlimited and they would otherwise
become cancers were it not for the fact
that the telomere shortened with each
cell division and Reign them in we would
be overrun by tumors runaway cells from
being informal speak for cancer well
runaway cells being informal speak for
tumors and then tumors become cancers
when those cells start uh
metastasizing and spreading around the
body but nonetheless yes it was tumor
suppression versus tissue repair
telomeres being the regulator that
balances these things and the balance
being the reason that we have such great
longevity right you don't want long
telomeres or short telomeres you want
balanced telomeres because they provide
the optimal uh the optimal uh
balance point between the two the two
hazards so what I'm getting at here is a
it's very interesting this the New York
Times report again reports on a New
England Journal of Medicine paper one
that the New England Journal of Medicine
thought important enough that not only
did they publish the paper but they
published an editorial on it because the
significance is so substantial
but what is so very odd is that this is
reported as if nobody saw it coming when
literally
my co-author and I published a paper
more than 20 years ago yeah let's show
that paper yeah
no I got it oh you have it
so here it is this is and I should point
out that you will see this is published
in the Journal of experimental
gerontology the title of this paper is
the reserved capacity hypothesis
evolutionary origins and modern
implications of the trade-off between
tumor suppression and tissue repair
now this paper has a bit of a history to
it this is actually
publication in experimental gerontology
following the rejection of a paper that
was very similar to this
uh By Nature one of the two premier
journals uh in the world nature
preposterously claiming that the topic
was not of sufficiently broad interest
of to Their audience to be worth sending
out for review nature actually
officially refused to review the paper
in spite of the fact that the paper was
sent to them yes Debbie cesic and I were
both graduate students at the time and
they could have overlooked the
significance of the paper but it came to
them with recommendations from George
Williams one of the greatest
evolutionary biologists of the 20th
century who specifically recommended to
them that they take it very seriously
and review it and a similar letter from
Dick Alexander my and Debbie's PhD
advisor
a member of your committee uh who also
strongly recommended that they take it
seriously and both I presume Williams
was but both members of the National
Academy right these were you couldn't
get a stronger recommendation for an
evolutionary hypothesis than those two
and yet nature flatly refused to review
it they sent it back uh saying it just
wasn't sufficiently interesting so after
that happened something that I have to
speculate a little bit about occurred
which is that I got a letter from
experimental
experimental gerontology saying that
they had heard about the manuscript and
that they were interested in us
submitting it to them
which we did I believe that that
happened because George Williams must
have contacted them back Channel and
told them uh that it was worth their
time in any case they ended up
publishing it finally in 2002 and
uh in any case it has been
um not widely discussed in cellular and
molecular biology and as you can see it
takes something like 20 years and
finally cellular and molecular biology
is catching up to the idea that there is
a fundamental trade-off that is adaptive
in nature and there is enough of a
hubbub about it that the New York Times
is reporting on it now let's look at the
paper that
um the New England Journal of Medicine
published so not the editorial but the
primary paper yeah the original article
okay so this the title here is familial
clonal hematopoiesis in Long telomere
syndrome and what this paper describes
so
there's a lot of inside baseball here
there are various things that were
predicted in uh in my original paper
that turn out to be true among them
um the idea that moles are actually
cells that have run up against their
telomeric limits we called them
prototumors which I still think is a
great term that ought to be adopted but
I've never seen it used by anyone else
Dermatological moles yeah Avogadro's
Number moles not Avogadro's number or
right exactly
um
so uh
I won't go into all of the detail but
what they have done here is they have
done the flip side of another piece of
work so back when uh we originally
published this paper
there was a question about whether or
not Progeria syndromes that was
accelerated aging syndromes the worst of
them being Hutchison guilford's Progeria
people have probably seen images of
these very usually boys these very young
boys who appear to be very very old they
look like wise and old men they look
like they're patently six eight ten
years old yes and they have virtually
every pathology that comes with old age
except for two one of them is cancer and
the other one is cognitive decline
um so interesting that those two don't
show up that would be predicted by our
hypothesis but in any case the reserve
capacity hypothesis did not exactly
predict what was going on with
Hutchinson Guilford Progeria turns out
there was a second mechanism we didn't
think of but we predicted that
Hutchinson Guilford Progeria and other
progerias would be the result of short
telomeres
it turned out that people who had these
disorders had normal length telomeres
that shortened at an abnormally fast
rate as a result of the fact that more
that cells were produced but didn't
stick so if you had to produce five
cells to get one that's stuck it
resulted in a five times the rate of
expenditure
of telomere so okay if you have
shortening telomeres that accelerate or
accelerated in their telomere shortening
and it gives you pathologies of Aging
except cancer and cognitive decline
which presumably functions through an
entirely different mechanism what
happens if you have very long telomeres
well that's what this is about so
um
they studied a syndrome called can you
scroll down to the abstract here they
studied the syndrome called is it humans
that they're looking at yes they studied
humans it was actually no back up back
up
um okay
so they studied people who have a
germline mutation in a gene called pot
one now normal pot one is
um
involved in the shortening mechanism of
telomeres that causes telomeres to erode
with cellular proliferation
mutations
in this Gene result in either additional
telomere being added or a reduction in
the rate of shortening but either way it
results in somatic tissues so she's out
in the body that have abnormally long
telomeres and lo and behold what did
they find but they found that people who
have this this mutation were
disproportionately prone to certain
types of cancers and a couple other
pathologies quote a range of benign and
malignant neoplasms involving epithelial
mesenchymal and neuronal tissues in
addition to B and T cell lymphoma and
myeloid cancers right
okay now there's a lot in there but the
basic point is hmm
the reserve capacity hypothesis turns
out to be true
um short telomeres result or a
shortening telomeres results in
increased uh pathologies of age
elongated telomeres result in an
increase in the chances of developing a
tumor or a cancer so that is fascinating
now it's strange though that not only
does the New York Times fail to mention
that there was an existing evolutionary
hypothesis that predicted exactly this
result but the authors of this paper
also do not cite it nor do the authors
of the editorial about the result they
both ignore it completely even though
the editorial for example
um uses a term about the rescuing of
cells from senescence by a by a
mechanism that adds telomere possibly
involving the pot one uh mechanism the
pot one gene so
I guess
first of all I don't want to be in a
position of
claiming that I know what the
significance of this work is that's not
mine to say we're not supposed to be
describing that about our own work on
the other hand what do you do in a world
where you do work you do it the right
way it is scientifically exactly what we
are asked to do which is to predict
things and to demonstrate that what we
have put uh into the world has
explanatory power on the spaces others
are supposed to cite it and what do you
do yeah what do you do there is a lot
wrong
with modern science obviously as we have
spent a lot of time talking about here
and elsewhere
the scientific process is often thrown
to the bus in favor of uh of
accomplishing political ends that
actually have nothing to do with science
we have talked a lot about how very
non-fundamental and non-central peer
review and certainly in its modern
instantiation is to the scientific
process in its modern instantiation it
being imminently gamable and thus gamed
almost entirely
but citing those whose ideas you are
invoking is absolutely necessary not
to come to know more things but to keep
track of where good ideas are coming
from and this this is something that uh
this is one of the things that I used to
insist on my students getting right and
uh you know these are undergraduates
everywhere from Advanced undergraduates
to freshmen who would almost always have
the question as most graduate students
do as frankly many probably practicing
scientists and and researchers do and
medical researchers do you know under
what circumstances do I cite like why
you know why are scientific papers such
a you know damn disaster to get through
for people who aren't scientific because
you always got citations in the middle
and it impairs the ability to just read
through right
you cite any idea that is not common
knowledge
okay that is easier said than
operationalized because at what point
does something become common knowledge
there will be there will be some
disagreement at that at that categorical
border because the Border itself is
fuzzy right well you know every most
people agree on this at this point but
not everyone do I still cite the
original
uh you know I would tend to err on the
side of giving the credit if it's not
really clear but
many people think you know we all
everyone scientists are not has in their
head like plagiarism is bad right
plagiarism is bad because
um ideas
are not
in the air
they emerge from Individual people's
brains and generally they emerge from
the collaboration between people's
brains at the point that it's conscious
but
we need to keep track of where the ideas
are coming from and who's got the good
ideas and very very often you find a
diff you know that there's there's ways
of
doing less work which is kind of
cheating in science where you say well I
I know this is true so I'm just not
going to bother trying to figure the
citation out
sometimes that's what's happening you
also have the oh oh okay this paper I'm
reading it's a good review and so I
don't have to go back and read the you
know 700 papers they reviewed I'm just
going to read this review oh they claim
this paper written in 2012 this really
good review paper pollution 2012 and
there's no reviews done since then
claims that this work in 1998 found X
okay I'm just going to claim that I read
that paper and I'm going to cite that
1998 paper about X
well when you actually go back to the
earlier paper and look for the claim X
it is alarming oh alarm alarming how
often the claim that was made by the
later paper just got it wrong
right and so you you if if you are
making a claim based on someone else's
claim The Honorable thing to do the
honest thing to do the only
scientifically you know rigorous and
careful thing to do is say this claim
was made by such and such according to
this later person but scientific
journals don't want you doing that they
want you finding the original resource
they want you finding who said it so
where in all of this does uh you're in
Debbie's paper from 2002 which is based
on work that you had been doing since
you know the mid late 90s
where does that fall into this somehow
you got disappeared right thank you your
work got actively disappeared and it
became
totally not just totally okay but
actually expected I think that that your
work which is hypothesis driven
theoretical specifically makes a number
of predictions that have been borne out
in the years since we will not talk
about that and that we will not talk
about that thing among scientists deeply
anti-scientific corrupt and a problem
for all of us because that way is the
end of science so this goes to a number
of places you you uh hint at one of them
when you talk about hypothesis driven
proper science is hypothesis driven most
people think that it's clever to say
that their science is data driven as you
and I have talked about data driven is
actually a kind of a coup that has been
mounted against hypothesis-driven
science by laboratory types who have
various reasons perverse incentives for
not wanting to be so closely obligated
to the hypothetical Realm but this is
the case for one thing evolutionary
biology
um as a field as a right to be
recognized when it succeeds in
predicting things in the laboratory in
other words is this just in you know is
it an abstraction is it like you know
studying distant quasars that it has no
meaningful application on planet Earth
no this actually has important medical
implications and important funding
implications you have entire fields that
have been studying what is obviously a
dead end from the point of view of
dealing with a pathology they've been
lying to each other about what is likely
to work are we likely to extend Life by
increase in the length of our telomeres
are we likely to cure cancer by getting
our telomeres to be shorter right those
two things have to come together and be
discussed and the point is you need a
proper theoretical context how do you
know what a proper theoretical context
is it makes predictions how good are the
predictions I don't know how much realm
do they are are they relevant to and how
early do they come
how risky were they you want it sounds
counterintuitive right but you want
risky predictions because a a non-risky
prediction oh that could couldn't
possibly not be true isn't much of a
prediction if the thing is almost
certainly true under a whole array of
circumstances it's not much of a
prediction a risky prediction is true if
and only if the hypothesis from which it
comes is itself true right and there's a
question about the
um you know okay so the work that it
turns out 20 some years later was
predictive of this result that both the
New York Times and the editors of the
New England Journal of Medicine
apparently think is very important even
if readers of nature wouldn't have
thought it was worth their time back in
but the implications May extend far
beyond those predictions in other words
we don't predict things in order to see
the results of an experiment early we
use experiments to figure out which
models of the universe are actually
closely aligned with an underlying
reality that we can't observe directly
and so this particular work also came
with another prediction about Mouse
telomeres so those who are long time
viewers of the podcast will know the
story maybe more than they'd like to
about the fact that what stood in the
way of generating the model that was
underlying the paper that Debbie and I
ultimately published was the fact that
there was a piece of evidence that could
not be reconciled with it which was that
mice had Ultra long telomeres that
wouldn't make any sense if telomeres
were mediating a balance between tumor
suppression and tissue repair you would
expect a much shorter telomere in mice
to deal with this trade-off in such a
small bodied animal
what turned out ultimately I predicted
that the what was universally believed
at the time that mice had long telomeres
that that would be false and that it
would be discovered if we were to study
the telomeres of wild mice that they
would have short telomeres just like
people and other mammals and so it would
be a laboratory artifact that had
created the long telomeres and mice that
had been measured so many times and if
that was true that had dramatic
implications for not only the study of
wound healing of cancer of senescence
all of the things that we would use mice
as a model organism for but it also had
very direct implications for
pharmaceutical safety because those same
mice are used to test compounds to see
whether or not they are toxic right so
toxic that you wouldn't want to release
them as a pharmaceutical the problem is
um what uh what I hypothesized was that
a selective force in the breeding
colonies from which laboratory mice come
based on the fact that
younger mice breed faster than older
mice and because these entities that
produce lab mice are sensitive to how
expensive it is to produce a salable
mouse they breed younger mice because
it's more cost effective what that does
is it means that those mice in those
colonies don't live long enough to get
cancer and so it takes this delicate
trade-off and it unbalances it wildly in
the direction of long telomeres are good
because they reduce the pathologies of
Aging so they are selected for in Mouse
colonies but the problem is
if you take a mouse who has long
telomeres that Mouse is condemned to get
cancer virtually all laboratory mice die
of cancer if you give them the
opportunity they live shorter lives than
wild mice because they don't have this
delicate balance they're unreliable
models of cancer because they're so
prone to it that they are unlike people
but worst of all is they will be
disproportionately resilient to toxins
that are not so deadly that they
outright kill the animal right a toxin
that is just simply very bad for the
animal that kills tissue but doesn't
kill the animal outright is something
that such a mouse can compensate for
because they have effectively an
infinite capacity to replace their cells
and worse than that
the fact that these animals are
condemned to get tumors means that if
you give them a toxin that is bad for
them but not deadly it may extend their
lives by slowing down their tumors it
functions like chemotherapy because the
way chemotherapy works is cells that are
in the process of dividing are more
vulnerable than cells that are in a
static phase so when you get
chemotherapy because you have cancer the
idea is we give you a poison and it's
bad for you but it's worst for your
tumor and you kill the tumor faster than
you kill the patient in mice that have
these latent tumors
giving them a toxin May extend their
lives and so when you say well is this
is this compound safe enough to give to
people well I don't know it extended the
life of these mountain of these mice
maybe it's not bad well maybe what you
just discovered is that it's a toxin and
that is not going to be very good for
people
um and that mice are very
um or laboratory mice are a very
unreliable model
so one of the problems with the many
problems is that there are so many like
sign changes in that story
that it's very hard to explain to an
audience that isn't already informed
and the audience that is already
informed that is to say those
researchers who uh work on things like
telomere and senescence and cancer
don't want to hear it
well they don't want to hear it but they
don't have any right not to hear it no
they don't that's that's the problem but
it's but it's a story that is
particularly easy for the public to miss
not that the public hasn't been forced
to miss a whole lot of stories that
shouldn't have been easy to miss at all
but this one is easy to miss
because it's going to be a really hard
sell
for the store a story whose sound bite
is
uh this drug is bad for you because it
being poisonous helped the drug help the
mice that it was tested on to live
longer agreed but all I would say is
look
people in the public
this isn't their job right
there are institutions whose job this is
right the FDA could be absolutely
obsessed with discovering whether or not
this is an accurate description of the
universe instead the Blue Ribbon panel
that was assembled after the viox
Scandal
assemble put together a 300 page book
called the future of drug safety in
which telomeres are not mentioned mice
are not mentioned rodents are not
mentioned right the book doesn't contain
anything in the neighborhood of this
question it doesn't falsify the idea it
just simply pretends there's nothing to
talk about and my point would be under
in under normal circumstance let's say
science screwed up badly and that this
thing somehow didn't get noticed
20 plus years after the fact it finally
Dawns on somebody that this thing being
in your paper yeah my paper and the the
model that it that it proposes okay so
they're 20 years late
shouldn't Gina colada
now be calling up the people who
She interviewed to report the story and
saying wait a minute was this predicted
you know shouldn't she be digging up my
paper and saying wait a second didn't I
just report a story in which this
appeared to be some brand new surprising
result and in fact here I'm looking at a
published paper in a respectable journal
in which the exact thing is described
ahead of time by two decades right
shouldn't that happen right what about
you know where's Nicholas Wade I
certainly contacted him about this Carl
Zimmer shouldn't Carl Zimmer be buzzing
with wait a second I heard about that 20
years ago what what happened why why is
this not in the story and yet they're
not going to because this is a
cozy Club
of people who are effectively
um
they are Doling out scientific results
at a rate that keeps them in their jobs
it does not serve the public
well uh
it wasn't supposed to be the science
journalists job to do this
there haven't been scientific
malpractice effectively
it then becomes the science journalist's
job to discover the story and unearth it
and figure out what it means
and sure yes absolutely the science
journalists should now be should now be
on it but uh
they're not
and I think more to the point
when it's so clear that science that the
the club
of people that are doing science On Any
Given domain is clearly just that it's
an Insider's club and you're either in
or you're not and if you're in you're
going to get your back padded and your
grants granted and your uh you know
can you review panel is going to be well
stocked with friendlies and you're going
to proceed up the academic or perhaps
corporate scientific ladder
and if you never had the expectation
that your work would be challenged on
the basis of whether or not it was good
if the entire game was played at the
social level all along
that's not science science wasn't being
done if it was entirely about who said
that if I like that guy then that's a
good thing he said and if I don't like
that guy then that's not a good thing he
said that's not how science is supposed
to work because science is trying to
science is supposed to be about the
process of discovering what is true
whether or not you like it whether or
not the person saying the thing that is
true is someone whom you like whether or
not the person who was saying the thing
that is true is saying something that is
true but in other Realms he says things
that are unsavory none of that is
supposed to matter
yeah it's not it's not supposed to
matter and the fact that in this case
you mean you're dealing with a bunch of
things of consequence and I agree with
you that there's a level of complexity
here that makes it hard to track but a
evolutionary biology
scored a win
right
um
correctly predicted things without the
necessity of
laboratory evidence on the basis of
theory alone there are a small number of
such predictions in the history of
evolutionary biology we get to add
another one right it actually works
right that's an important piece of
evidence about how significant this is
how much we should invest in
evolutionary theory also a bonus that it
actually Builds on one of the other
major theoretical predictions
antagonistic plyotropy from George
Williams 1967 not 57 57 57 yeah
um right so this is a great story it's a
multi-generational story of success of
an evolutionary line of reasoning a very
elegant one that ultimately arrives at a
mechanism which you can validate in a
laboratory study that's pretty cool
right it also in the context of the hell
that we have just gone through with
covid right
yes you and I were entitled to bring
that success let's say we lost our minds
you and I have lost our minds but we
haven't lost our minds 20 years ago
right we are entitled to say hey here's
a past success and here's one where it
took two decades for the field to catch
up right so that raises the question
right are we now
nuts or are we just a head right and the
fact that this can be disappeared means
that you and I are dismissable on the
basis that well who are we we're not
even functioning academics right okay
but so what the point is this is a
significant success and again I don't
want to be talking about this I want
somebody else to figure out whether this
is significant and I want to be able to
stick to the scientific part of it but
if you've got effectively everybody
across the board pretending
that the hypothesis wasn't out there
that of interesting new result has
emerged out of nowhere because some
clever laboratory scientists thought to
investigate the question then the point
is well okay somebody's got to point out
that there's in fact a hidden history
here which isn't all that hidden
well and it also so I have not read the
New England Journal of Medicine article
I hadn't I hadn't heard about any of
this until shortly before we went on air
here
but um
is it hypothesis driven
if it if it is from Once the hypothesis
is a question and if it is not
this is not I mean you've already said
I've already said it we've already said
it many many times but you know absent
the preceding hypothesis the work itself
is not a test of anything and so if any
time we're people with fancy machines
and computers fast enough to run very
high power cystical tests
say oh I can just collect a whole bunch
of data over in that sphere and then see
if any pattern emerges when I tell the
computer to do some stuff and go aha see
I found it I go what's that you found oh
well it's the thing oh let me see what I
think that means
if you're trying to figure out what you
think it means afterwards
that means that you were
poking around the dark and poking around
the dark is not what science is supposed
to be doing poking around in the dark is
is effectively it's haphazard at best
and random at worst this is poking
around in a self-inflicted darkness
which is so strange because you think
that scientists are out there trying to
get ahead of each other and that that's
you know it's sort of ugly that it's a
competitive business but it drives us to
see things these are people who are
striving not to see what's in front of
them and here let me show you Zach will
you bring up the New York Times uh
article the Gina colada article
now scroll down
below the picture there's a picture of a
woman who has this mutation there's her
okay uh this is just the limit of my
building being able to see it here let
me read it yeah from the beginning oh
yeah
there were though some
sorry that wasn't you I don't think
um there were though some puzzlements do
you want to read it now that it's big
enough to read yeah some organisms even
have crazy long telomeres like mice said
Dr Dr Benjamin Ebert chairman of the
medical oncology of medical oncology at
the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and
mice don't live that long
okay this is a sentence written in 2023
that says that mice have crazy long
telomeres okay now can you bring up my
article
uh that's gonna be on my computer
okay and then
yeah bring it up
and then scroll down
to the end of the abstract like I'm not
going to be able to read maybe back up
uh would their children stop moving it
where do you want me to start reading
from um
we observe that captive rodent breeding
protocols designed to increase
reproductive output simultaneously exert
strong selection against reproductive
senescence and virtually eliminate
senescence that would otherwise favor
tumor suppression this appears to have a
selection say again
and virtually eliminates selection that
would otherwise favor tumor suppression
all right this appears to have greatly
elongated the telomeres of laboratory
mice with their telomeric Fail-Safe
effectively disabled these animals are
unreliable models of normal senescence
and tumor formation safety tests
employing these animals likely
overestimate cancer risks and
underestimate tissue damage and
consequent accelerated senescence so
that is a scientific sentence
it was properly contextualized and was
up to date in 2002
Gina Colada's article saying you know in
fact there were paradoxes uh mice have
crazy long telomeres and they don't have
long lives that is a sentence that would
have been foolish 20 years ago in the
current context with this other result
now having been validated a telomere a
telomere-based Nobel Prize has been
awarded Carol Grider has given a Nobel
lecture on telomere length in mice in
which she like everything else here
describes things upside down she
pretends that the the extrangely long
telomeres of laboratory mice are a good
thing because of all the weird things
they allow us to see but nonetheless
this it's not a secret right it is being
dealt with in this bizarre way that
prevents people from putting two and two
together and getting four but
nonetheless it's not a secret it's been
discussed everywhere but it's been
discussed in a way that just does not
allow credit to flow anywhere that is
not preordained Works in part
because perhaps everyone
there may be a few
few odd people in the world for whom
this is not true but nearly Everyone
likes story
understands human interaction
and so this science journalism so-called
is being told with quotations and a
little bit of human interest and this
and that and the other and it's much
more dry to keep up on the literature
and go in and say ah this is predicted
here and here's what we have it's much
both easier and easier to sell the story
to the editor presumably and to the
readers of the New York Times and you
know it would be the readers of anyone
I'm not
particularly going afterwards and New
York Times here to say I'm gonna I'm
gonna make a phone call to one of the
trusty people in my you know modern
Rolodex and get a get a quote that works
and that feels really sciency and it
also breaks up the you know dense
scientific speak and
oughtn't that be good enough because
they're the people who are paid to keep
up on literature aren't they and so the
failure is yes at the journalism level
but first it's at the scientist level
it's at the level of the people who are
supposed to be doing the science and who
are claiming to be doing the science and
who are holding the torch for Science
and letting it go out yes but you know
at the beginning of that you alluded to
the narrative
and the fact is The Narrative of
evolutionary biology seeing something
that laboratory science didn't see or
refused to see and it having dramatic
implications about human health about
our capacity to do future science right
that's a good story and there's a reason
that it doesn't show up and it's not
because it isn't a good story it's
because that story is threatening to
something that is in a position to Snuff
it out yeah and
um that is I think deeply troubling it's
not that human health does not ride on
the question of was this knowable right
this was knowable it was knowable 20
years ago it had implications it's
important in for example
you and I were taking a task by Eric
topel on Sam Harris's podcast
well Eric topel became famous I believe
in the fight over what happened with
vioxx so in some sense his coming after
us is two schools of thought on what
happened with the viox Scandal and
um our school of thought has just scored
a major Triumph but it will not be
recorded that way and therefore Eric
Topol will still come to the battle as
you know the highly decorated professor
and you know you and I are I don't know
people who went to a college were
teaching was the primary thing and you
know left during some bizarre meltdown
right that's not how it is
scientifically speaking there's actually
a track record on both sides and
um and the implication couldn't be more
important for issues in the present like
um Public Health policy during covid
like uh pharmaceutical safety over that
same period like The evolutionary
implications of vaccinating into a
pandemic and what that had to do with
the proliferation of variance the point
is
you are supposed to take your track
record into that battle and when you say
something surprising your track record
is supposed to cause people to calibrate
right are you a crank well if so newly
so right because there's a long track
record of being right about things in
this area surprising things important
things it was part of why
um as much as uh many in the scientific
and medical establishment wanted to do
so it was hard to dismiss Kerry Mullis
out of hand when he started saying
things across a number of fields that uh
that you weren't supposed to say and of
course the idea that there are things
that you aren't supposed to say on
scientific domain is itself distinctly
and should be immediately suspect like
that tells you right there that you're
not playing in science land anymore that
this is something else yeah uh Carey
Mullis and Luke Montagne and I would say
that to the extent that something like
you know Nobel prizes are awarded for a
reason those guys both had one and the
point is they came to any argument no
matter how counter-intuitive what they
were saying was both of them came to the
argument with the official sanction of
the Nobel Prize and that meant yeah they
could easily be wrong but the point is
the chances that they were wrong just
because they didn't get it was pretty
damn low because they had gotten it to a
level that exceeded what most people do
in a career and anyway I guess
um
I am simultaneously uh tickled to
discover that
um I mean a I gotta tell you having been
told
as a graduate student that the
um fact that we grow feeble because we
have a cancer protective mechanism that
that idea wasn't interesting to Nature's
audience I mean it was obviously an
insane thing for them to say at the time
but it is sort of fun to have the
Vindication of oh well now everybody
seems to be interested in that you know
now that it didn't come from
evolutionary science it came from the
laboratory people are fascinated by this
enough that the New York Times is all
about it but
I am frustrated at the degree to which
uh the failures of the system that is
supposed to be the system in which peers
are reviewing each other's work to make
sure it meets a certain quality one of
the things peer review is supposed to do
is that people familiar with the area
are supposed to tell you oh you failed
to cite that result and you didn't
account for that thing so they're
supposed to know it and they're supposed
to hold each other's feet to the fire
over it and it's not supposed to make it
into the publication like New England
Journal of Medicine unless it has you
know reached a standard of carefulness
and thoroughness that it justifies
publication there that system doesn't
exist right that system is more likely
to force you to exclude things in order
to make it into the club so that you
don't you know
rock the boat for those who are you know
at the top of the field that is deeply
frustrating to me and having watched
so much harm done over the uh the covid
pandemic by bad science being sold by
bad journalism right it's just this
feels like uh you know it is
simultaneously a wonderful Vindication
and a slap in the face
yeah that is what it is and a
demonstration uh that uh many are
resolved to have learned nothing which
means next time it will be worse yes and
we're still learning that yeah continue
to learn this thing yeah
all right
um
let's just talk for a couple minutes
about this one last thing sure if if we
may I think you have not read Louise
Perry's most recent unheard article it's
called modernity is making you sterile
is that right I have not read it so
she's a fantastic writer and thinker
um
she let me pull this up uh wrote don't
don't show my screen just yet Zach she
wrote the book the case against the
sexual Revolution and is host of a
podcast that I had not heard of before
looking at her byline here uh the
podcast is called Maiden mother
matriarch which is a fantastic name for
a podcast
um but uh I read this piece and I'm
going to read just the the opening
paragraphs for us today and I and
before doing so I don't actually know
her politics I take her to probably be
sort of classical liberal maybe maybe a
conserve maybe a little bit right to
center I'm not really sure
um I think this piece is I'm gonna I'm
gonna link to this in the show notes uh
and we won't talk about most of what's
in this but I find it just an excellent
example of well-reasoned
um tight scholarship beautifully written
I disagree with a few of the points made
rather strongly agree with a whole lot
of other ones and feel like this is the
perfect example of the kind of thing
where can't people from all sides of the
political Spectrum come together in good
faith with
the data and stories and truths at our
disposal and say okay where do we
actually disagree in terms of the values
rarely more to the point more often in
terms of what the recommendations are
for how to go forward so I'm going to
read just the first few paragraphs and
then talk about one of the things one of
her suggestions in here that I sort of
write like oh God no but I also
understand where she's coming from
uh so modern yeah you can show it now
this is um in oh did I say unheard I'm
sorry this is The Spectator
um modernity is making you sterile rage
against our demographic Doom published
May 7th of this year
cassava is a woody shrub native to South
America Perry writes for people living
in drought-prone tropical regions it is
a godsend delicious calorie dense and
highly productive the indigenous peoples
of the Americas who first cultivated
cassava are reliant on it and have
developed an arduous days-long process
of preparation that involves scraping
grating washing and boiling the plant
before it is eaten
at the beginning of the 17th century the
Portuguese introduced cassava to the old
world but they did not import the
ancient methods of processing assuming
that indigenous people were wasting
their time
we do not always know why we do the
things we do this applies as much to
indigenous peoples as to Modern
westerners the first cultivators of
cassava could not explain why the
scraping grating washing and boiling
process was necessary but they did
because they did not know could not know
that every step of the process is
essential in order to reduce the cyanide
content in the plant
if even one step is skipped
it's a chronic cyanide poisoning is the
result
and the Really devilish thing about
cassava poisoning is that the buildup of
cyanide in the body is so gradual that
it is almost impossible to identify
cassava as the culprit
that's the problem with what we all
think of as progress It's swatswave
benevolent traditions because the
usefulness of traditions can be subtle
and hard to understand technology brings
many blessings better Medical
treatment better nutrition and better
comfort for all of the world's
population even in the poorest regions
but rapid technological development
liquefies well-established traditions
and sometimes we don't realize what
we've lost until it's too late
so that Preamble reads I mean it's it's
very much the message of our book of
course we don't happen to tell the story
of cassava in a hunter-gatherers guide
the 21st century but we tell many others
that are that are like that and the
message is one that of course we
resonate with because we've we were
teaching that we've been teaching that
for decades and is what we wrote into
our book yeah in fact uh It lines up
with both uh literally false
metaphorically true and uh chesterton's
fence which that's right both play a
large role in our book yes uh
chesterton's fence for those who are new
to um new to listening or uh to us being
the
it's I guess a parable Parable uh from
GK Chesterton a um early 20th century
philosopher writer thinker
um who uh tells a little story about two
guys walking along and running into a
fence one of them says that's in the way
let's get rid of it
uh the other one says what's it here for
says I don't know let's get rid of it he
says you don't get rid of it until you
know what it's there for only if you
know what it's there for and can
establish that the reason that it's
there is no longer relevant then we can
talk about whether or not you can get
rid of it until and unless you know why
it's there you don't touch it so um it's
sort of it's a it's a
inverse while pushing in the same
direction as the precautionary principle
so you can if you would give me my
screen back here for a second
um
she she goes through an analysis that um
that that we've got vast fertility
declines especially in the weird world
Western educated industrialized rich and
Democratic
um we have actually I'm not sure that
we've talked publicly about the reality
actually that there are two simultaneous
population crises on the planet that go
in opposite directions and yet
completely do not cancel each other out
and so you know she's talking about the
fertility declines which um which
suggests a looming demographic disaster
but it's also true that there are too
many people on the planet to be
supported in a manner that can allow us
all to be healthy eating good food
having access to the kinds of things
that most westerners want access to yeah
I would
because I know what trouble we're going
to get in over that claim I would say
the point is really a consumption
there's too much consumption and the
problem is the technology to allow that
number of people to Coexist on the
planet without consuming at a rate that
is unsustainable doesn't yet exist now
it's not inconceivable that it could but
at the moment it seems like too many
people because the rate of consumption
requires a destructive interaction with
the planet yes yes like that
okay so then she talks about
um
all of the some of the ways not all the
ways we actually talk about a number of
other ways that modernity is is
affecting our um
our standard of our quality of life but
also our fertility and she talks about
some of them and one of them she puts on
the doorstep of of modern feminism the
kind of feminism sort of third wave
feminism she doesn't call it that but
that I always used to call faux feminism
f-a-u-x feminism not f-o-e although it
kind of works either way
um but this this sort of feminism that
um forgets history forgets what we are
just wants to prioritize doing what you
do when you want to do it and looks
really naive as a result Perry frames
this as a kind of Freedom First like
Freedom individual Freedom as the
primary
um
primary thing that is desirable and
feminism and she writes
um
we need to marry modernity with a
culture that promotes and supports
Parenthood and you can show my screen if
you want but you don't have to because
it's just one paragraph
a feminism that prioritizes freedom
above all other values will never be
able to achieve this goal which is why
we need to be fashioning a feminism
oriented towards care and
interdependency orientated she writes
and if we are going to attempt this then
we will need to look at people of other
times and places with new eyes and
rather than assuming that they were all
bad and stupid as the progress narrative
does instead thinking carefully about
which norms and institutions actually
serve the interests of women
in pre-modern Europe women would remain
in their homes for the first 40 days
after giving birth in a period known in
English as lying in initially they would
stay in their beds in their bedrooms
with female relatives neighbors and for
the wealthy servants temporarily moving
into the home and tending to their needs
and the new babies okay if I might have
my screen back now
she then advocates for this and she
reports on how demanding very early
motherhood is and how she herself ended
up being alone
in some medical need but also with a
newborn after her husband went back to
work and advocating for
um you know basically both antibiotics
and lying it
and
um
I read about the lying in thing which
I've heard before and I think I
literally shuddered with horror as you
can imagine yeah I would have wouldn't
have been your thing the idea that you
would be literally imprisoned in your
home
um not able to not allowed to go outside
uh in the month or month and a half
after your child was born
sounds like complete hell to me and also
sounds deeply deeply unhealthy will
there be circumstances of the birth of
the pregnancy of the baby of the of what
is happening outside the home where that
might be exactly what is warranted sure
absolutely but for most women whom I
knew who had um you know relatively easy
pregnancies and relatively easy births
and had Healthy Babies
the idea that you should be stuck first
in your bedroom and then in your home
and not going outside with your new baby
and that means the new baby doesn't get
to go outside either doesn't get to get
any sunlight on his face doesn't feel
freshy or anything that looks like a
recipe for ill health for disease
actually and again there may be
circumstances in which that lying in
period would be good but the idea of oh
we need to go back to that
no no no we do not the idea that we
should be recognizing that isolating new
mothers with newborns especially if they
have no support especially if they also
have a reason that they shouldn't be
moving around very much is of course
going to make it harder on new mothers
and you might see for instance a rise in
oh I don't know postpartum depression
obviously like obviously this is a
problem of the way that we are
encouraging people to mother now as
opposed to something that was going on
five thousand years ago 10 000 years ago
how how common was postpartum depression
5000 years ago not very right it just it
wasn't a thing and no I can't have the
data to support that but I am certain of
this
so
um there's a lot I mean it's not
surprising Mary Harrington and Louise
Perry are friends and obviously there's
a lot of overlap in their perspectives
um and this reminds me a little bit of
the conversation that I had with Mary
Harrington and you know there's a
question
it's nowhere to go back to right one has
to go forward going forward is a problem
because the precautionary principle
which is not easy to adhere to because
of chesterton's fence which is not easy
to adhere to but at some level we need
to get serious about solving this
problem what do you do
when the current way is not viable
backwards doesn't work for various
reasons because we don't live in the
same place for one thing but also it
wasn't all that
well let's put it this way some ancient
Traditions are awesome yeah but
the idea that traditional gender roles
are what we should be aspiring to right
is anathema to a lot of people who
aren't crazy insane with third wave
feminism yep uh there's nowhere to go
back to there just literally isn't and
so there's a question about how you deal
without oversimplifying the problem how
you deal with the discovery of a new way
that does retain the values that were
correctly prioritized in the old ways
without ever being explained right how
you hybridize that
with a new world in which some of the
parameters have simply radically shifted
that's not an easy job and
um one of the things I greatly
appreciated about Mary Harrington was
that she was absolutely ready to have
that discussion right she has a bias
about effectively thinking that not only
should we go back but we should go back
farther than we think
um but uh the discussion that ensued
around the question of oh that is
actually not possible what do we do
going forward given that for example
birth control is going nowhere right
that is a radical
change and it Alters the entire
landscape here
you know what what would it look like to
succeed going forward in defining a new
mechanism for being that preserved what
used to exist that worked and replaces
that which used to work and doesn't
anymore or what doesn't work in the
present I guess I will also say
um
I don't think it's a hedge but just
anecdotally with regard to our my and
our situation
um in both in the case of both of our
boys births my mother came up either
just in advance or to her
great sorrow hours after after the birth
um and stayed for many weeks
uh
you
are as active and participatory a
co-parent as any band I have ever met
and even at that stage where there was a
lot of stuff to do with parenting that
you just don't have the
anatomy and physiology to do you were
very very present
um and also there are a number of mostly
women but also some men at what was
still a functional college that was both
of our employers at that time and in
both cases they um they organized and
brought in a number of
um you know a couple of weeks of of
dinners for us and so there we did have
some support now during the day I was I
was strapping the baby to me and going
out on walks because that was what I
needed to do that was what was that was
what felt healthy but without
um
you being who you were without my mother
there without the support of our friends
and colleagues it would have felt a very
very different thing and so there is no
argument I would never make an argument
nor would I think it would be sane to do
so that um you know a woman should just
go into motherhood totally solo and
expect it's going to be fine that makes
no sense yeah and that has never made
any sense
um I would also point out though that
you know it's weird the idea of laying
in right okay that's some arbitrary
moment in the past in some particular
she argues that it and I haven't I don't
know that this is true but she argues
that it was nearly ubiquitous across
cultures I don't I have not run into
that before but that is the argument in
this piece well then here's the question
okay virtually every hunter-gatherer
Society maybe even every hunter-gatherer
Society at least the ones I'm aware of
babies are carried passively as mothers
go on about their hunting and Gathering
right and this has lots of potential
benefits right for one thing there's
lots of subtle stuff that gets
communicated you know rhythms of Life
kinds of things just the experience of
you know we spend a certain amount of
time in this kind of activity or that
kind of activity the
um one of the ones I found most
interesting
was that uh babies and mothers establish
a kind of communication about the
um the babies need to uh to poop and
piss that allows for a diaperless world
in which you're not constantly running
into terrible things because you know
when the baby needs to go it subtly lets
its mother know this the mother finds an
appropriate place no diaper is necessary
this becomes impossible in a modern
society or sheets right in the land of
elevators and offices and sidewalks and
all sorts of things that then result in
us making the very terrible choice to
effectively tape the feces to the baby
that's not a normal thing to do but it
also it also results in
the baby losing touch so if a baby would
naturally be in touch with its own need
to excrete things and then it loses
touch with it because we effectively
cannot allow the baby to be doing that
anywhere and everywhere as a
hunter-gatherer could then we have to
reteach them you know these things which
is an unnatural and broken mechanism and
so fun for No One fun for no one yes
um but anyway the point is we where are
we well
you can't go back
right
we're stuck with
the fact that many people live in modern
circumstances where they can't just
behave like a hunter-gatherer going back
to a laying in Period indoors where you
know I'm sure that if you were laying in
I think it's lying in at least as she
spells it here
all right lying in if you were lying in
presumably in Europe
how many hundred years ago are we
talking about until relatively recently
but I think she may have said medieval
I'm not sure medieval so you know at the
very least certainly if it was Winter
probably almost any time there'd be a
fire which you know has some sort of
positive benefit the point is we are at
an arbitrary place in technology all the
time right and that arbitrary this is
this is a very important Point actually
um that it it feels to everyone
presumably like
we've arrived we are here we are the
moderns we have arrived and from here on
out it looks the same going forward but
man there's a lot of yesterday looked
different and a week ago like really
different in a month and wow but good to
have arrived right now right here
because now things stop now we're modern
you can relax
which turns out not to be true right
have I introduced you to the AI
um but yeah we're always we are now
Always Somewhere arbitrary and so what
that what the upshot of that is
necessarily
as fraught with danger as picking and
choosing from the arbitrary collection
of options is and it's not going to be
good I mean you know she opens with the
killer point in this piece right the
cassava story is definitely a a
beautiful example of the Japanese
suspense issue now in the hubris which
until recently was always oh those
natives they just don't know what
they're doing and now now it is revealed
like actually the hubris goes every way
all the time constantly we're always
assuming we know more than we actually
do and maybe don't mess with that until
you oh never mind well the natives don't
know what they're doing go Nick
stimulize yourself
um you might want to spell that out no
it's a it's a corn processing
methodology that makes the Beast
properly digestible and uh did you say
Beast yes you don't think corn is a
beast no all right well so and it's
referred to as liming yeah
yeah in any case
I I think you know and you and I spelled
this out really directly in the book
can't go back there's nowhere to go back
to and going forward is not going to be
a there's not a method for doing that in
a way that is without Carnage but you
know going back full of Carnage going
forward is gonna be full of Carnage the
question is how do you minimize that
amount of Carnage and
um not keep repeating the same errors
right how do you how do you learn from
those errors and you know at some level
reign in the impulse to embrace the new
because it does seem improved right you
know oh
compact fluorescent light bulbs really
you want to stop eating tuna you know I
mean you know you've got Mercury that's
suddenly in the environment at such a
level that tuna fish is a concern that
really shouldn't be
um you know oh let's replace it with
LEDs LEDs they're super efficient you
know that'll be great for our carbon
footprint ah but you know how is it for
our physiological health
there was I did not care to talk about
this um but I I understand that there's
a new piece of legislation being
um pushed forward or maybe it's not
legislation some new standards being
pushed forward by the button
Administration uh to lower what I think
is actually already a pretty low number
of Maximum gallons that is going to be
allowed to be used in any standard
running of a dishwasher
and the time period uh during which all
dishwasher manufacturers have to abide
by this thing is something alarmingly
short like three years
and um for all new dishwashers all new
dishwashers yes I don't think anyone is
going to come into our homes and steal
our dishwashers from us
um
I don't think I didn't say it won't
happen I said I don't think that's
really that's yes new dishwasher
standards
um I think again I didn't prepare this I
think it was like at five gallons
already like energy star like it was a
water consumption was already a concern
and now it's going to go down to
something like 3.5 for full
3.5 gallons per cycle and again I may
have those numbers wrong but this struck
me as so
naive so
unaware of even the most basic
trade-offs uh that it's I mean it's just
it's just one thing after another with
politicians at this point like really
water is the only thing you care about
what do you think the water is doing
have you ever washed a dish by hand can
you simply reduce the amount of water
you use by a third and have it work just
as well if you can you really weren't
being efficient in the first place but
there's already efficiency standards on
these machines so it's not like these
are water guzzling machines now if they
were okay you cut it down you cut it
down you cut it down
but
There Are Places
where water is not that limiting and you
know what is always a problem is the
detergents so it's water and it's
detergents and what's all in those
detergents a lot of nasty things where
do they go are you gonna need to use
more of those if you use less water
probably
I'd rather use a little bit more water
and less of this crap totally right yeah
so water reduce the water use why
because you can spell water and you know
what it is and everyone has an idea of
what it is like this is so backwards
everything about these these political
just like we care about the environment
because we're reducing water consumption
I can reframe that to make it clear that
you don't give a rat's ass about the
environment by doing this yeah
it is oddly the same thing we ran into
with covid policy where there was an
obsession with you know antibody titers
or something that did not properly take
a integrative measure like all cause
mortality right we have some measure yes
that would actually be worth shooting
for an improvement in and instead we're
going to measure something else because
it allows us to say a lot of complex
stuff that doesn't turn out to be true
like yes you know yes okay this energy
has an R rating of such and such right
it's therefore better than this other
one who has an R rating that makes it
you know
20 less efficient okay but how often do
you have to replace the sealed panes
because they've gotten a leak and where
does the energy in the production of
those pains figure into the equation you
want just some sort of net analysis
right yes there it's terrible to waste
water because it's expensive to procure
and you know we do a lot of throwing
away of perfectly drinkable water even
as we're polluting our water and
requiring people to do their own
filtering and all of this nonsense but
it's not like
we are for some reason making all of
these puzzles harder than they actually
are
yes while standing up next to some
simple graphic
um that looks like it'll help people get
elected next cycle which you know that
that's an old game that's an old story
that's nothing new but it seems like the
pace of these things coming out and the
the obvious naivete and that's being
kind that is behind these things is ever
more clear yeah
all right well on that happy note let us
um let us bid you and you uh you can
return to a spring yes we are going to
return to Spring we hope that you too
can return to Spring although
unless you're in the southern hemisphere
Then Fall it is yes and for most of you
it's it's uh probably it's later than it
is for us but still it's gorgeous here
if you're in the Pacific Northwest and
you're in the Sailor sea or anywhere
along the west coast of the US
um do join us next time we'll be back on
Saturday which is May something uh the
14th maybe you know the 13th I think and
um will be back then along with a q a
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside see you in the future
[Music]
thank you